[Music]
asked me not to introduce him because he
needs no introduction
he is a great benefactor of MIT and his
his company medical information
technologies you may understand there's
some relations of the initials of that
it is in 4m Meditech right they call us
meditech rather then what I prefer they
call us but but but Neal is very kindly
agreed Institute to talk to us tonight i
i'll start very simply i first and
foremost have nothing to do with
university teaching i have nothing to do
with university research
therefore I'm completely unbiased and
everything that was talked today was
meant basically about that that subject
and I don't know that much about that
subject but what I do know is about
software technology or what it's
generally referred to today as
information technology I started a
software company called medical
information technology too big a
mouthful they chose to call us many tech
rather than MIT that's fine that's fine
now I'll go with Medi tech it so it's a
nice abbreviation perhaps the earliest
software company in America and
therefore the world started in 1968 I
founded it I continued to be the CEO of
it a couple thousand employees private
company not a public company private
company we make software strictly for
hospitals 98% of it is involved with the
clinical process of delivering
therapeutic care a few percent is the
administrative stuff that I get forced
into doing for hospitals basically it's
clinical information systems
we're very very good at making software
our existence our life the 32 years
attests to that we really know how to
collect information clinical information
we really know how to store clinical
information we really know how to
retrieve clinical information forbes
duly made a comment earlier one of his
talks about five megabytes for a some
sort of image we need five megabytes to
store two hundred thousand discrete
pieces of information
quite often numeric quite often
qualitative information and certainly
quantitative information about patients
it's a big challenge it's easier to put
an image store it over there and
retrieve it it's very hard extremely
hard to extract from two hundred
thousand discrete pieces of information
that are stored about a patient over a
number of years to extract the right
information present it to the right
person at the right time for them to
make a clinical decision that
information is highly structured
information but it's extremely important
to be able to get your hands on the
piece or pieces of information that are
needed here and now to effect
therapeutic care we're very good at
doing that we've been doing that for 32
years I like to believe we could do it
for another thirty two years I myself am
the principal architect of the company
in addition to be the founder and CEO
and I run the business but I've got ten
officers who really run the business and
I can continue doing what I've always
done which is making software the
software we make
first and foremost its integrated
clinical software and I'll explain show
you a little bit about the integration
concept what we try to do is empower
hospitals the reason for the empowerment
of hospitals is because in a community
they are the major use of medical
technology that is the center of
clinical technology in the community
it's the central point at which we would
expect the most use of technology to
improve diagnostic procedures to tell us
what's wrong with our patients and just
as important therapeutic procedures to
make our patients better and that's what
hospitals are they have a tradition of
being high tech and what we try and do
is empower them so they become the focus
of medical care for the community they
become the focus they become the area
where we would expect the proper use of
not only machines like MRIs and things
like that which we think of as high-tech
machines but also information systems
they become the focus for the whole
community we would expect the hospital
is where the you would go if there was a
serious problem sure we all would might
have primary physicians in a doctor's
office that may be able to diagnose cute
problems may be able to diagnose chronic
problems but in all cases we were feel
comfortable that the hospital is there
to cater to our needs in a very very
high-tech situation what we try to do is
orchestrate the clinical process
orchestration is a it's a great word we
think of a whole Orchestra right we go
to go to the symphony the advantage that
conductor has in a symphony is very
simple
he gets to look at the 50 people that
are playing the music and those 50
people get to look at the conductor I
die
the conductor can orchestrate them to
work in a way to produce great music in
a hospital we'd like to think that your
surgeon or your intern or resident is
thinking only of you there's no one else
when you have a critical problem that
they're dealing with or worse yet a
family member of yours we'd like to
think the physician is only thinking of
you the physician is looking at you 24
hours a day and vice versa you could see
them not only the physician the other
minions that help the lab techs the
nurses everybody involved in a clinical
process but in reality no one's looking
at you very often it's only not the
physician at best he might look at you
in the eye if you're a patient I don't
know five minutes a day there were
literally 25 other people 24 hours a day
that are performing diagnostic and
therapeutic procedures on you and by the
way
unlike the symphony they're doing that
for 25 other people each person in the
hospital at the time you're there is
doing procedures for you and procedures
for 24 other people simultaneously and
at different points in time even you may
be in a preoperative stage there may be
someone with the exact same problem you
was in a post-operative stage and the
people that have to do work for you
quite often are not looking you in the
eye they're dealing with the numerous
other people simultaneously
No if symphonies were conducted that way
where the musicians couldn't see the
conductor and the conductor couldn't see
the musicians and the musicians were
playing not only the music you're
hearing but 24 other pieces
simultaneously the music would sound so
well and it's even worse at least with
the symphony the author of the symphony
has written the score from beginning to
end and place the score in front of the
musician and as well as in front of the
conductor and the conductors problem is
to simply lead the that process through
in the hospital setting and in fact in
the individual doctors office music
isn't done performed that way instead
the conductor picks one note and he
gives it to one musician and says play
that note and after that note is played
he picks another note and cans it to
another musician and says play that note
and then of course picks another note
foreign tolling another piece and gives
it to someone over there now of course I
hate to admit this is about the worst
possible process that we could ever
imagine human beings being involved with
and yet we all expect a successful I
don't know procedure being done when we
go to a hospital we really accept that
thank you
now we're good at communicating storing
and retrieving information well let's
give some examples
my talk of course has to do with
eliminating the middleman
the reason the middleman has to be
eliminated as the middleman is the
source of error in procedures a recent
study was done indicating that about a
hundredth that we kill about a hundred
thousand Americans each year through
medication errors and the primary reason
we kill a hundred thousand people a year
of medication errors is there's too many
middlemen in the process a physician
order something the likelihood of that
order being properly conveyed to a
pharmacy is you know 50/50 the
likelihood of the pharmacy filling it
out and sending the medication back to
the floor 50/50 the likelihood of the
nurse grabbing the medication and giving
it to the right person another 50/50 and
you come down all these things just no
wonder we kill a hundred thousand people
having said that having said that the
importance is to eliminate the middleman
I'll give a couple examples of
eliminating the middleman first my first
example is patient education we expect
the nurse they actually educate patients
and patient families about what's going
on because show-me physicians have no
time to do that so it's treated as a
don't worry about it oh you're in good
hands I'll take care of you don't ask
too many questions and we'll we'll get
through this all right we obviously
believe in empowering patients put down
here pulling information and pushing
information for 30 years and as a
continuation we believe the importance
is to pull information people use the
internet and browsers as if these are
the epitome of information we of course
suffer from a total information gut so
if we are to provide patient education
in a pull form it would look like this
here's a it's a browser it's an internet
browser it's looking at patient
education then Betty Tech provides I
just grabbed our product and link to it
we can look at oops
we can look at procedures done on the
brain strokes we can look at diabetes
type 1 & 2 we can look at heart thing
various types of information that a
patient would want to know OBGYN
lungs surgical procedures this is the
classic poll we rely on the individual
this case the patient or patient's
family to pull the information to them
that they need to know how do they know
what in for me there's so much
information out there how would they
possibly know but of course it's kind of
neat you know if I look at let's take a
surgery let's take a gallbladder removal
this is what we would present or so to
read this we're talking about a
gallbladder I know if anyone's ever
experienced a gallbladder operation this
is the part of the
patinated the liver and gallbladder send
vial through ducts or passageways into
your intestine
sometimes bile hardens and stones form
inside the gallbladder these gall stones
can lie quietly and not cause any
problems
however if gall stones get stuck in a
bile duct or cause inflammation of the
gallbladder your felt there may have to
be removed this procedure is called the
cholecystectomy because the gallbladder
is just a storage bin the bile your
liver may simply goes directly into your
intestine when we clearly try to do is
eliminate the nurse or the doctor from
telling you about stuff like this
because they don't have the time to tell
you stuff like like this
we use animation so that the blood
doesn't spurt out just below your rent
one instrument helps grasp the
gallbladder another instrument carefully
closes off the ball
the surgeon Maronites the gallbladder
toward the incision where it is emptied
and flipped out the entire surgery
usually takes from one to three hours
let me exit this and hop to something
else
lungs asthma for kids of course what I'm
showing you is something that expects
the user the patient the patient's
family to know what they're supposed to
look up
or we
because the breathing tubes in your
lungs too close up and get clogged with
a lot of meal good sort of like your
nose when you have a cold if your
breathing tubes close up too much and
make too much mucus air has a hard time
getting in and out of your lungs I'll
stop this point out the condition is the
sort of the second choice tells you
about what's wrong with you other things
how do we treat that okay how do you use
an inhaler if I went to that one
presumably it would teach me the proper
way to use it inhalers I won't let these
things go on I've got you know we can
you can spend a half an hour learning
about things but simply to point out
that we're big on patient education to
eliminate the middleman freeing up
nurses to give you more direct care
trying to answer as much questions we
break down education that's the second
time I hit this button here there'll be
a slight pause well this warms up the
on/off switch it's not my display if
there it is really that was quick
treatments self care what you yourself
should do do for yourself I don't know
how to make that go away it'll probably
go away when I press another button or
it'll go away when I pause or go away
when I hit
ah you went away by itself modern
technology indistinguishable from
medicine and the pull technology we
don't know exactly what your physician
wants you to do we don't know what test
the physician might want to do for you
so we educate you about all possible
tests for this thing here we don't know
what buzzwords we should educate you on
to understand various buzz I'm just
zipping through here buzzwords
du jour of all the different things they
say around is a sound here I sort of to
pronounce these words and I've sort of
suppressed that the point is this is
pull technology we present to you a full
menu of all possibilities the classic
argument is too much information is
presented to you you as an individual if
you don't know what to do we contrast
this with the poll version of the same
information sorry I lied to push
information of the same information that
was the demonstration of pull technology
you can go and look at a vast repertoire
of knowledge if you know what you should
be looking for the push version is very
different the push try again push
version is excellent I'll use that as my
next joke talking about a joke I have to
interrupt for a joke you know snom was
talking about which blew me away you
know 80% of these Asian Americans aren't
going into mechanical engineering or
something like that but reality I'm a
full-blooded Sicilian Lincoln's wine
does 80% of Sicilians go into crime and
I was thinking only a few of us go into
what we would consider honorable
businesses
[Laughter]
what happens is an email is sent to the
patient an email containing a link to
this first page and instructions on what
the password du jour for that patient is
to enter I was told the password du jour
for me was Neal dot Neal that's my name
it's show me not a Sicilian name same
kind of thing patient education there's
a big difference though my care
I'm presumably going to the hospital for
heart failure heart failure doesn't mean
your heart stop beating by the way so
the clinical tournaments troublesome it
doesn't work the way it's supposed to
work but it doesn't mean it died in your
died I also because I happen to have
diabetes as a chronic disease that's
also there and there are other important
items I no longer will see the general
information associated with all the
clinical information I will see
information that's specific to me my
physician has pushed this information to
me from the vast collection of
information out there chronic heart
failure boson tells you a little bit
about chronic heart failure the point is
now we're using a push technology
through the email we emailing to patient
a patient's family specific information
that they have to know for their visit
to the hospital this is how we're going
to treat your chronic heart failure
these are the drugs we're going to give
you the specific drugs these are
specific tests we're gonna perform in
you when you're at the hospital so we've
taken a whole vast amount of information
that our voice is simply a voice over so
if you can read you can know what
they're talking about
if I look here
back to VU care specifically the drugs
that you're going to be given while
you're at the hospital
you're going to be given coumadin this
is the actual monograph exactly what
it's there for
hmm I'm just gonna page through some of
this information but the point is by
using push technology we take the vast
amount of information that's possibly
out there and stylize that specifically
what we want you to know that's an
example in patient education I won't
belabor it anymore the self-care are the
exact procedures that you're supposed to
do thank you he told me that the first
time he stood up it was ten minutes
second time he stood up it's 20 minutes
and the third time he'll stand up would
be thirty minutes okay that's an example
of pushing information versus pulling
information browsers the epitome of
pulling information email the epitome of
pushing information shows how we can
educate patient patients family without
a middleman for the woman here I could
have said a middle woman but I think
woman would prefer the middle man be
eliminated
doctor's orders pulling information well
we've been very good for many many years
being able to let physicians or
clinicians pull information Wow
such a big deal stupid it's a bad idea
how do I know that I'm supposed to look
at information I'm a physician how do I
know it's time to look at one of these
patients I don't know how I know
assuming I select them I can obviously
have some buttons here I can look at
patients in where I physically am or I
can look at my own patients but in all
cases how do we know what patient I'm
supposed to be looking at information
for so I'll guess that this guy Fred
Jones got a lot of rub I'm about some
demographic and I got we we're very good
we give very simple buttons around the
peripheral to let the coalition easily
select what they want to look at but I
ask you how do they know what he does
they want to look at who told them to go
look at Fred Jones and in particular if
they told him to look at Fred Jones who
told them to look at what information
about Fred Jones should I look at the
flow sheet should I look at the
chemistry should I look at blood bank
medications based on that should I look
at that information in items by time
should I look at times by item should I
look at more information should I look
at less information
who knows and yet we're very good at
putting out simple buttons to let people
look at information there's a little
scroll bar here so I'll give you one
without a scrollbar
who knows what to look at this is the
classic Paul we all think the epitome of
computer technology is the browser I
submit to you the browser is worthless
in an information glut society what
possible mechanism airs to know what you
should look at well I compare this with
this is simply numeric data by we can
look at it and graphs and every which
way but the point is how do we know what
to look at
let me deep-six this one and go to the
next page which is the push version now
the push version to means we can take
any data that we're so good at storing
and we can wrap it around with HTML type
stuff to take any bait any display we've
ever been able to do with any elements
we can wrap it up in HTML stuff what
good is it to look at if you don't know
which one look at so what we choose to
do instead is to take the right data
wrap it up
both diagnostic data and therapeutic
data and email it to the physician in
church very simple concept here's some
examples of it here I really should be
looking at my front screen of my email
which gives me messages cuz I am
assuming those four messages something
about pain something about drugs
something about x-rayed about various
patients came to me in my email system
you know that you have mail someone
wants my attention and I pick the first
one
55 year old female John John Homam Jane
Doe she weighs 80 kilograms I know this
information was initiated by a nurse
because the first chunk of data is the
qualitative information that the nurse
is the one who initiated this
now your patient I'm presumably doctor
Pappalardo your patients been claiming
of increased pain does I happen to know
this particular patient came in for
pneumonia chronic condition of arthritis
of the knee has been causing your
increased pain we've been currently have
her on a current pain medication that's
existing data I'd have to go search for
this data it came to me in one email
message the crisp information that I
want to know patients complaining about
Dave about pain this is the pain
medication I'm currently on here's my
order set what do I want to do about
this I can continue treating with this
drug I can treat with that drug I could
treat with this drug just I'm a
physician I can do anything to hell I
want to do shouldn't we have if we have
pharmacist involved the pharmacist job
is to keep the physician under control
the order is always sent to the
pharmacist whose job it is check for
medication problems with other
medication drug in or in a fair a whole
bunch of stuff so no it doesn't get by
the pharmacist anyways what is paid for
no not not that not at this level not at
this level I can send also qualitative
measurement back if I want a message
back you know that tell me how she feels
later blah blah blah blah whatever I
want it whatever I wanted to say either
case this is an attachment to an email I
submit it I'm done that information sent
back to a computer computer would deal
with this mention we have intelligent
email systems to deal with things of
that nature next example
this is not from a human being there's
no signature here this is from a
computer a computer sent me this email
hospital policy is after I give a
narcotic 72 days 72 hours later that
narcotic will expire I have to renew it
it's a computer-generated email
specific to me telling me exactly what I
want to know giving me the opportunity
to do whatever I want without having to
search around the neighborhood for
whatever it is I'm supposed to do
same argument could decrease the dosage
with or without a message submit it I'm
done this is presumably a patient who
came in for total hip arthroplasty
do a hip surgery remove the hip put her
on and she's in pain she's in serious
pain it needs some really hard drugs to
deal with it I'd submit it and again go
on to the next thing another email x-ray
data here I primary physician have a
patient outpatient he's here because I
suspect the smoker they suspect cancer
in the lungs I've asked for an x-ray
I've ordered it I've wanted interpreted
by the radiologist I as the primary
person know how to interpret an x-ray if
my life depended on it
thank God patients don't know that
doctor Lemke here presumably has said I
want you to reorder this it's got some
shadows in it I can't tell if the spots
are real or the spots of shadows wants
me is the primary physician to reorder
it I'm sure if I look down later I'll
see how to order the x-ray again I can
change choose the position these are
just different ways they look at x-rays
I can tell whether stat means do it
immediately routine is when you get
around and doing it
once again check what I want add a
message submit it I'm done once again I
have pushed the on off button modern
technology why is there nine off button
boy
that's a very interesting question being
Sicilian I have a very simple answer for
it
do I have to embellish that answer
anymore is that it we by the way are
simply the providers of information the
ultimate decisions are made by
physicians physicians don't in any way
delegate their responsibilities to
someone else so we've been in business
32 years we've never been sued let alone
lost the suit an issue of that nature
one more example here's an example which
is the wave of the future in the past
mistakes are made because we have a big
feedback loop I don't know if you know
how medicine works we measure things
about you based on what we measure we
change therapeutic procedures there's a
patient John Doe forty-five year old
male came in fundamental problem is a
blood clot in the leg well simple way we
treat blood clots is we give them a
medication which should increase the
time it takes to coagulate blood
medication is heparin we're given this
and of course we want very much to
increase the time it takes to clot blood
so we have a test
it's called PT T if anyone wants to know
what it means it's up on top their
partial thromboplastin time I like to
call it the time it takes for your blood
to clot this patient came in the first
thing we did is gave them a major inject
amount of heparin major amount and at
the same time
ordered a PTT test but it's now come
back is the result from that PTT test
124 seconds that really says it took 124
seconds for your blood to clot
presumably it took you know 12 seconds
for the blood to clot when they had
because it was clotting too fast and
that could have caused that so came back
124 seconds well what we submit to the
physician is you should not in health
care go back to the old-fashioned method
of I give you a drug I order a drug for
you I order a test for you and when the
test comes back to PTT I look at it
possibly in real time possibly and when
I get around to it and based on that
value modify the drug increase the
dosage if we're not clotting for
clotting too fast or decrease the dosage
if we're clotting too much whether if I
set it right or wrong I don't know but
it doesn't matter that feedback loop
which is continual does the same thing
that one of the speakers said today it
creates immense overshoots and
undershoots but who cares human beings
we assume their physiological system can
deal with that anyways in this
particular case we said rather than
involve 30 distinct orders of
therapeutic procedures and diagnostic
procedures being done over time I will
order one thing for you I will order a
protocol but I since I'm responsible for
you for a patient I don't want to be
kept abreast and here I'm getting a
result back through my email again the
latest measurement of the PTT test was
124 seconds we are currently dripping
heparin into your body that's 30 minutes
right I'm just about ready to finish
we're dripping heparin into your body at
thirteen hundred and fifty units of
whatever you want to call them per
or the automatic protocol says if you're
at 124 seconds somewhere in here we're
supposed to it's kind of high we're
supposed to hold the drip we've out this
the overshot the patient came in you can
believe they were clotting very fast up
here we overshot our mark the no change
when the desired goal we're gonna hold
the drip by 60 minutes automatic
protocol and wait an hour and then
decrease the drip by 300 so it'll be
dropped to 1050 you as a physician
should be aware of this you can do
either of two things you can ignore
everything we sent you make believe and
never happen you can order a PTT test
right now you could actually change the
protocol which I've chosen not to do but
in either case and then you do that in
this case by telling them change the
protocol because the protocol is what
you originally ordered and we want to
make sure you would dock in that
changing from that protocol but here's
an example of an overshoot due only to
the rough measurement of that algorithm
right the male gorilla ms based on the
weight of the patient and it shouldn't
be in such things like a hundred or 200
- and we can do with the actual amount
we can change things like that that
completes what I want to say to you let
me summarize again all aspects of
medical care involved middlemen we want
to obviously remove them from the
process they simply introduce errors we
have very good algorithms we would
prefer ordering protocols rather than
individually ordering therapeutic and
diagnostic procedures in some apparent
way but in in reality a haphazard way
which quite often introduces overshoot
and undershoot we obviously want to make
the physician in charge of the patient
acutely aware of the information they
should know
about the patient without having to
winder through a browser or a pull type
technology to find it that's the end of
my comments I'm more than happy though
[Applause]
there's any short questions because I
know it's late people want to go home
and yes how do you pick up the
information who doesn't who does what
pick up the information I missed the
question they got how do we back up the
information well computers computers
actually work for years at a time today
we use very thin server technology which
is extremely highly reliable and we
constantly backup information because
it's distributed information through an
institution remember I said before we'd
like to empower the hospital to be the
primary reservoir of the information for
the community we've got something like
in the Houston area medical information
and about 300,000 pay patients that's
accessible in any medical institution in
the Houston area yes simulators are
presumably to say we help the educate
the clinicians not my job I'm only
interested in educating patients I
assume the Commission's already start
out educated so I would like to believe
that I can help them do their job more
effectively with less errors by
providing them with the right
information at the right time to do
their job
I don't educate physicians
yes how are using this at any point in
time I currently have 1500 active
hospital accounts at any point in time
there's my prior technology my current
technology my next technology this by
the way is my current technology we
started selling this kind of stuff six
months ago we probably have today a
dozen hospitals using this out of the
1,500 if you ask me to question tomorrow
just add another zero to the Dozen we've
been fortunate that we've had 15 have
1500 active hospital accounts since for
32 years we've lost under 20 of them so
we constantly upgrade and continue
making our hospitals the type of
hospital I love with the community
hospitals type of hospitals I hate are
the major teaching hospitals and
specialty places like Boston nice to
work in Mass General Hospital I would
never sell anything to Mass General I
was in a university business and never
sell anything to MIT either do you mean
by HMO an insurance company is that what
you mean by HMO
that's what HMO is it is an insurance
company well what I submit to you
especially the push technology has an
intrinsic benefit and cost the current
way to make medical care more
cost-effective is to lay off nurses and
cut back to size of the of the staff
because people are 80% of your cost
you know successive layers but I still
say the way to reduce costs right now is
to cut back staff and don't do things
because cut back to staff of course they
don't do anything we can't do it because
you cut back to staff to do it the first
way if you are a business you want to
control your costs first order effect
lay off people trouble with laying off
people it decreases the quality of care
notwithstanding it's the people that
caused the errors in the first place but
I'll still submit it decreases the
quality of care what we're trying to do
is eliminate the middleman eliminate the
need for people and at the same time
improve the quality of care because
we're making the process more efficient
that's what we're trying to do yes over
there
you'd like to put it first on my list
well that lists there for the the drug
one is the this physicians favorite pain
medications that one there there's one
here this is that physician whoever that
physician is doctor Pappalardo
this is what I tend to use it's my
favorite set of pain medications if you
a physician wishes your own set of
course that's what you would see your
own set we do the simple thing we give
you the hospital standard we let you
through your minions because God forbid
we would let you modify your own set of
orders on a computer through your
minions we would allow you to change
your to your favorite order set yes I'd
only have one answer so they could try
to go ahead well we've got 1500 active
hospitals in the US and Canada is about
4,500 total so we got a third of the
market you're asking the wrong person
can I ever admit that someone else could
do as good a job as we could do I would
say this though I'm one of the
old-timers in the medical information
business my reputation is such that
anybody in medical information systems
generally knows who I am everyone else
who was either in the business is either
for old they're dead and if they're
young they're Young Turks okay so I'm
stolen for all right I'd like to believe
that I have pushed the state-of-the-art
continually in this business my life
cycle of being 32 years old and the
business attests to that this is
obviously something that the physicians
are a little concerned about right we're
in a sense sort of telling them what you
should look at what you should choose
from a short list
we're constraining freedom of choice you
know going to McDonald's and ironing off
a menu is constraining freedom of choice
physicians would like to be held in a
somewhat higher esteem than being chosen
reducing chief read him a choice I don't
hate physicians I've said that earlier
I'll say it again it's not my job what I
want to do is make physicians deliver
higher quality care at a lower price
it's all I want better care cheaper
price yes this is our trivial everything
we do is trivial I said well we're very
good at is taking a collection of data
for a patient in organizing and in such
a way constantly appending we don't
erase that we always append to the end
of the file that's my business that's
what I do you know I don't know it's
what I do I don't know to me it's
trivial you know we're good I said
earlier we're excellent at gathering
data storing it away and allowing
ourselves to retrieve subsets of it I
don't consider this rocket scientists
what you heard most of today is rocket
scientists this is as trivial as if Ken
I submit to you I mean it's so much
easier I said it takes some data out of
the person's file I I wrapped some HTML
around it and I sent it to them in an
email attachment email how many people
don't use email right nobody here the
waiter I'm sorry I'm the cameraman you
use email Hey
you know come on give me a break here
this is taking common sense methodology
there's a big difference between pull
and push and that's this trivial concept
as we could ever hope to explain but
most people I heard altogether I didn't
hear anybody mention email today in a
conference they mentioned using bloggers
browsers look at but for teaching
everything else but I didn't hear
anybody mentioned the most fundamental
reason that the whole computer
technology started doing something
useful yes first we never allow
passwords to be conjured up by the user
passwords are always generated by the
computer they're generated at least
every 30 days and you get a new password
every 30 days whether you like it or not
and so we are anytime we pushed off do
you especially in the patient education
one that was clear we had to push it to
you because you're gonna get on a
browser to go to go access the
information but anybody could get on
that we don't want to identify who you
are so we simply tell you type in this
is the password du jour to find out
what's happening yes well if your
physician we would send you private
encrypted email sure but that doesn't
mean I i bypassed the sign-on I hope you
didn't mind that for the demonstration I
can you know they're gonna get in a
there's always a way for them to
properly identify themselves now is that
the end solution of security of course
not but the point is the more secure we
make information the harder it is to
deliver good good care you know anyone
else
hey thirty etcetera I'm on
[Applause]